hey youtubers it's Charlie so Marvel
posted this funny infinity war teaser
I'm going to play it there's a really big
character that the Russos accidentally
revealed is going to be an infinity war
but we'll talk about see if you can
guess who it is while you're watching
the teaser infinity Wars is it's really
going to take the cake there's going to be two star wars of our generation we thought
that the most compelling way to start
off infinity war would be to have the
Avengers right off to the ends of the
earth in complete conflict with each
other when the greatest threat that
they've ever faced shows up and it's
setting the groundwork for infinity war
but you know civil war is not finished
it's going to the story will continue
the story of this family will continue
into into those movies civil war was
very much a good warm-up for us in terms
of the storytelling for infinity work
because we were we're dealing with such
a large number of characters what I have
seen so far in her so far is is just I
mean they Marvel dirt each time it is it
is huge the IP not just in the sort of
scale of what they're going to attempt
to do visually but just story-wise the
ideas are just massive and and so much
fun if anywhere the approach of those
movies that are that they're combination
films and that they're going to
culminate everything that has come
before them and any you know Marvel
movie up to this point so it's really
banding together all the characters of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe to face
this threat together they didn't reveal
a whole lot in that teaser but that's to
be expected they're only promoting civil
war right now so if Marvel probably has
their own team of winter soldiers
following cast around to make sure they
don't reveal anything they're not even a
hundred percent done writing the story
for both films but they have most of it
enough to start shooting which is
actually starting pretty soon though the
real details that we know about the film
come from a bunch of different
interviews that they've been giving so
the Russo said that we're going to
continue to explore cap and Bucky's
relationship a lot of that probably got
left on the cutting room floor when they
decided to do civil war for Captain
America 3 because if they hadn't done
Civil War they probably would have done
more Bucky flashback it would have been
more of the story of Bucky being framed
for something that he didn't do cap
trying to save him
more of the story of someone trying to
get over this mental disability that the
Bucky has but also the cap Ironman
relationship they said they'd be
exploring whether or not they can repair
the
no surprise here spoiler alert nothing
brings people together like the threat
of imminent universal destruction at the
hands of the Infinity Gauntlet at Thanos
but there'll be a lot of like that
juvenile Tony Stark foot-stomping before
that happens he's definitely one of the
most prideful Marvel characters but
Robert Downey jr. just so charismatic on
screen that he makes it work he doesn't
come off as much of a total asshole as
he did during comic book Civil War I
think we can thank the Spider Man Ark
for that but the other big relationship
that they kind of explored they didn't
really deal with it in civil war too
much was Scarlet Witch and vision
because they even had that line in Civil
War where she acknowledges that he's the
only one who's not afraid of her and we
found out that she can control the mind
gem that's embedded in his head because
you have to remember that both of their
powers flow from the mind gem so
naturally she's still going to be
connected to it even if it's not
physically connected to her the way it's
connected to vision vision had more of a
protector role during Civil War I think
it'll be a lot of fun to see those roles
reversed in infinity war because Thanos
is going to want the mine gem to form the
Infinity Gauntlet so he's going to have
to forcibly take it from vision which is
kind of like saying he's going to take
visions humanity there's that moment in
civil war where iron man turns to him
and says I didn't think you made
mistakes like this as if he's saying
vision derped like a human would vision
is very shaken says I didn't think that
I was capable of mistakes like this
either as if he still has a long way to
go in exploring his humanity that'll
continue an infinity war but I imagine
because he doesn't have the soul gem
it's not going to be so much Santos
taking his soul as him taking his
humanity when he takes the mind gem from him so now Scarlet Witch is going to have
to be his protector the overarching
metaphor that the writers used was that
it's going to be a lot like Pearl Harbor
and that they will be totally unprepared
for Thanos's assault but I know I put
that big question to you guys before the
teaser about who the big character the
Russos accidentally revealed in case it
wasn't already clear they're talking
about Captain Marvel
they said that she would be in it like
an actual physical actress would be cast
and she would be one of the big
characters in infinity war the same way
black panther and spider-man were in
Civil War so Marvel has been really
quiet about who they're looking at
they've had people working on the script
for the solo film but it's still a long
ways off but the reason I think that
they haven't announced who the actress
is yet is because they have something of
a dr. strange situation Marvel really
wanted Benedict Cumberbatch for Doctor
Strange
but because he was so busy Marvel could
not get him to sign a contract because
you know because Marvel's famous for
making people signed huge contracts it
took a couple years but they finally got
him so I think Marvel has just been
going back and forth with the person
that they really want for Captain Marvel
but their biggest candidate I think is
still going to be Emily Blunt Marvel's
done a really good job of going after
really awesome creative indie directors
but I think it still looks for
relatively bankable stars for these big
solo films but there are a couple other
big names that have been thrown around I
just I feel like Emily Blunt is still
one of their top picks but they
definitely have a list of people so they
don't get heard there's going to go down
the list I know a lot of people want
Katheryn Winnick I think she's an
awesome actress I think she'd be a
badass Captain Marvel but like I said I
think that Marvel wants to go with the
relatively bigger name the other really
cool stuff everybody's asking about
Thanos because he had nothing to do with civil war what is he doing is he going
to be in Thor Ragnarok so the director
for Thor Ragnarok has been tweeting up a
storm with James Gunn and a couple the
other big Marvel directors it's
hilarious do I have to put the purple
guy with the floaty chair in my movie
James Dean's reply yes it's a law now
you have to so that is this one of the
reasons why I love Marvel so much right
now at least Marvel Studios the film
side of their business part of the
reason for the big studio shift behind
the scenes in the way that they report
to people at Disney is so that Kevin
Feige can go after smaller directors
like this people who are amazing
directors but just haven't done major
super giant films before they had all
that drama last year about Ike
Perlmutter who still controls Marvel TV
studios controlling the film side of the
business and people up at the top
butting heads so they got all that
worked out so Marvel can just go after
like really awesome talented people and
there isn't as much political stuff
behind it because before that I think
Kevin Feige was forced to go after like
big-name directors which isn't always a
guarantee for success
but I just I love the idea that Thanos
is going to be in Thor Ragnarok and this
is how they're unofficially confirming
it I got to put the purple guy in the
floating chair in my movie okay I guess
it's a law I guess I'll do it but if
you're unsure about what's going on with
that movie I've done a couple videos a
lot of what's going on in that movie
thematically draws from Jack Kirby's
version of Ragnarok that was the time in
the comics when he was trying to replace
the Asgardian characters with the new
gods which ended up being a DC franchise
because Jack Kirby went to DC when he
was working on it but think of Thor
Ragnarok
Thor's version of the Winter Soldier
movie in the way that shield came
crashing down
so Asgard has been infiltrated by Loki
Thor like Captain America going to tear
it down to the ground and restart big
reboot for Asgardian society the movie
will address what happened to Odin and
it is starring Cate Blanchett who I
think is going to be a version of hella
ruling over Thor's version of Hell I
just can't wait to see her in the Marvel
Universe think of what she would look
like is the most evil version of
Galadriel like Elad Riel with the ring
of power during that nightmare sequence
during Lord of the Rings so let me know
in the comments that you know based on
all the stuff that they've confirmed and
teased about infinity war what do you
guys want to see in those movies beyond
Thanos assembling the gauntlet and
seeing a version of comic-book infinity
war and seeing the Avengers clean it up
just to get you guys a little more
excited about phase 4 the Russos who are probably going to stay on after Infinity
Ward they definitely sound like they
have a lot more steam in them a lot more
than Joss Whedon had after Avengers age
of Ultron they said the next big
character that they really want to go
after in terms of borrowing characters
like spider-man is Wolverine
the problem with that is that Hugh
Jackman is only doing one more Wolverine movie he's doing his old man Logan movie
and then that's it for him so that's
definitely going to cause some issues
down the road but they did the same
thing with Andrew Garfield and Tom
Holland so if they recast Wolverine in
the next 10 years
I think they'll totally get him for a
Marvel cameo eventually I just I think
it's going to take a long time but my
next big video is going to be all about
Voltron I'll post that later tonight so
be sure to subscribe to get it
and actually a giveaway time
congratulations to this week's Marvel
giveaway winner Justin Stewart you win
two imax gift certificates just be sure
to private message me on the back end of
my channel for contact details that's
just on the about page so because
there's all kinds of Civil War Marvel
stuff still happening I'll continue to
do the giveaway I'll just I'll start a
new round whenever I post my next big
Marvel video while you guys wait for my
next video to post you can click here
for all my Civil War Easter eggs and you
can click here for my post credits scene
video
thank you so much for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight!